[Musique]
bonjour à tous bienvenue tension par les
sports pour ce quatrième numéro de la
saison ne va pas faire les choses à
moitié il y aura comme d'habitude des
analyses des débats et des duels avec le
chroniqueur ils sont quatre autour de
cette table aujourd'hui présentation on
commence à ma droite mesdames et
messieurs nous avons la chance de
recevoir un champion du monde de
cyclisme sur piste master's sur notre
plateau le capitanat ya déjà réalisé la
robe vichy 68 est avec nous aujourd'hui
aujourd'hui la musique a eu un peu de
mal on est perdu complètement la voilà
vous avez bien moi super ok bon alors on
passe de l'autre côté musical incarne
l'élégance sur ce plateau c'est
également une redoutable sportive à la
rippe réalisés à des figures incroyables
en pole dance un sport qu'elle pratique
à versailles notre ambassadrice de
charme
hélène il te plaît bien je suis ravie
d'être de nouveau là
quand allez-vous mais très bien et vous
parfait on dort bien mange bien tous
croient tout va bien tout va bien
l'hiver commence approche mais tout va
bien
deyres de l'autre côté à musique qui
nous vient lui aussi de versailles n'a
pas sa langue dans sa poche est
aujourd'hui un incontournable de cette
émission le gladiateur pierre chevalier
du rugby-club de versailles est avec
nous salut michael salut à tous ses
vieux copains quand allez-vous pierre
pourvu que ça va très très bien on se
protège des frimas qui arrive et on est
content de retrouver la chaleur du
studio voilà chemin du plateau et de ne
pas habiller chaudement soient flamands
pour cette émission aura quand même un
petit peu une petite laine on termine de
l'autre côté musique on termine par le
meilleur d'entre nous il est aujourd'hui
un mythe une légende de ce talk ses fans
l'attendent à l'extérieur du studio
notre super chroniqueurs spécialistes
rugby coach
ex-entraîneur de plaisir est avec nous
et b bonjour hangl très vite les fans
qui attendent à l'extérieur vous leur
répondez quoi et ça j'arrive je suis un
bandit c'est au thème de l'émission je
vous propose de parler de golf direction
les greens du golf national de saint
quentin en yvelines d'après le tour
européen
vingt-quatre mille deux cents
spectateurs sont venus assister à la
mundi open de france de golf du 17 au 20
octobre le décompte officiel est deux
fois moins important que pour l'édition
il y aurait six mille cinquante
personnes par jour en moyenne malgré la
pluie et la fraîcheur automnale de cette
semaine là c'est un demi échec pour cet
open qui a vu sa dotation divisée à part
trois cette année suite au retrait du
sponsor chinois à chênée ce qui a
entraîné un déclassement sportif du
rendez vous l'année prochaine
l'événement pourrait être organisé dans
le sud près de khan une réaction sur ces
chiffres
pierre chevalier pas surpris on en avait
déjà parlé lors des précédentes
émissions il y avait un il y avait une
conjoncture pas très favorable pour une
épreuve comme seul comme celle là de la
saison en plein automne
le déclassement vers la fin de la saison
la saison des tournois pas de pas de
tête d'affiche présente
et puis des sponsors qui change et cette
épée de damoclès qui qui pointait en me
disant que effectivement le l'open de
france pouvait ponctuellement ou dans la
durée quitté le golf national
donc on va dire que c'était c'était ce
qui était malheureusement redoutée
on va pas dire attendu parce que ça
c'est celle utilisée par deux ses gonds
quand vous dites demi échec je pense je
n'avais jamais je pense oui je pense que
c'est vraiment un échec
à ceci près que je ne pense pas que la
fédération française de golf notamment
[Musique]
avait de gros gros objectif sur cette
édition les savait que ce serait
difficile en termes de communication ça
a été plus light en termes de
partenariats de vente d'hospitalité et
c'était plus light le plateau n'en
parlons pas ce qui sauve un petit peu la
mise et on en avait parlé la dernière
fois c'est la victoire de nicolas
colsaerts un francophone donc un belge
francophone sur le sur les terrains du
national maintenant place aux place au
débat pour pour 2020 il ya pas mal de
choses à dire je pense qu'on n'en
parlera n'est donc pas surpris
malheureusement sur cette édition 2010 9
qui avait quand même pas mal de pas mal
d'inconvénients contourner pour en faire
un vrai succès surtout un an après la
ryder cup 2018 et l'open de france 2010
genre vous qui êtes un passionné de la
petite balle blanche
qu'est ce que vous en pensez voyez ça a
été déjà dit c'est vrai mais en plus si
on leur ajoute à ça le les conditions
climatiques qui était pas favorable à
faire venir du négoce soleil ou pont sur
les bords nouvelle est meilleure au
niveau des chiffres toujours toujours
puisque il est certain que pour propres
du spectacle des spectateurs sur un
parcours de golf et il faut quand même
il faut quand même un peu de soleil
parce que sinon même avec un pas mal
qu'ils vont dire tu as vu le tag qui
fait je vais pas aller me caille et
c'est sur les bords du green
donc si on rajoute les conditions
climatiques et puis aussi la date
puisque on avait déjà dit la dernière
fois et v non mais c'était le choix dans
la date qui était pas bon parce qu'il
est entre deux tournois quoi mais
c'était pas façon une belle idée mois
d'octobre non mais on en a déjà débattu
ces fonctions-là chaud mais oui ils
n'ont pas eu le choix mais c'était pas
du tout le monde y est d'ailleurs bon
pour 2020 outre le fait qu'il soit
déplacé la date aussi sera déplacée je
pense qu'on voit sur des meilleures
notations une annotation plus que 37,7
millions d'euros de dollars à l'époque
oui mais là et là les chiffres varient 5
et 3 way of et ça fait c'est pas
millions dont celui de fourchette
2 5 et 3 c'est une fourchette contact
d'affluence du coup quand on regarde
bien tous les chiffres et je trouve
qu'ils s'en sortent pas si mal que ça
circule à 30 personnes par jour oui mais
donc quarante mille l'année précédente
ok ça si on me dit attends 640 quelque
1200 spectateurs c'était le double
l'année prévoit là le double alors que
le prêt de pujols a été des greffés de
beaucoup plus et qu'on a eu des
conditions climatiques qui ont aussi
freiné les spectateurs rient ça veut
dire que au final
au final si on réfléchit un tout petit
peu quand on essaie de trouver du
positif dans l'histoire ben l'histoire
est pas si elle n'est pas si moche que
ça sent le il ya tellement de points
négatifs de leur côté que finalement la
baisse de fréquentation elle est pas si
elle est pacifique significativement les
passionnés qui était présent puisqu'il y
en a un tiers des golfeurs et des
licenciés qui sont en ile de france
on était vraiment bien servi et ont tous
dit entre deux averses étaient il ya eu
notamment de jeudi une très belle
journée
même le samedi où il a pas fait trop
mauvais était vraiment servi et d'au
plus près de l'ensemble du champ des
joueurs même s'il y avait de grosses il
fallait il fallait être motivé
pas forcément puristes il fallait être
motivé pour braver parfois les éléments
savoir que moins de monde égalent plus
de proximité avec les avec les champions
donc là c'est vrai que ceux qui ont fait
le déplacement était vraiment je pense
très satisfait maintenant maintenant
s'ouvre une nouvelle ère pour l'année
prochaine de savoir en l'art des
passants en juillet en dépassant le open
en juillet et vraisemblablement dans le
sud
ça permet peut-être aussi deux ont dit
on au lieu de redorer le de redorer un
petit peu le le nom de l'open de france
de lui donner un nouvel élan après la
ryder cup et après les éditions qui se
sont déroulés au greffe nationale il
reviendra de toute façon au golf
national ça c'est une évidence puisque
maintenant c'est un c'est un parcours
connu et reconnu
les simples ça vaut peut-être le coup de
lui redonner une petite une petite
jeunesse un petit coup de un petit coup
de boost en le faisant devenir itinérant
comme il l'a été d'ailleurs à travers
l'histoire dont on parle beaucoup du sud
de la france
oui oui ça c'est sûr on parle de on
parle de terreblanche les autres et qui
est un magnifique magnifique parcours
resort européenne torv tour vnews donc
qu'ils peuvent largement accueillir
accueillir tout ça c'est mal joué
d'autres comment dire d'autres
conditions
on sait pas au niveau des sponsors on
aura peut-être pu finalement des
personnes un peu inattendus qui vont
venir voilà sponsoriser l'événement
n'ont pas encore loin de golf les
prochains mois et puis on verra
peut-être que ça fera bouger aussi un
peu de personnes ailleurs qu'en région
parisienne on verra si par rapport aux
vacances scolaires c'est favoriser pas
favorisé sa sera d'autre condition de
l'allemagne on en avait déjà parlé aussi
on sait très bien que
noppen qui est délocalisée de la région
parisienne fait aussi moins de
fréquentation donc ça alors nous allons
maintenant passer au programme de
l'émission aujourd'hui nous allons
parler du pg et de la livraison en 2022
du nouveau centre d'entraînement du club
font également un coup de projecteur sur
la colline d'elancourt le site pourrait
ne pas accueillir le vtt aux jo de 2024
mais avant de développer ces thèmes on
va parler cyclisme focus sur les
championnats d'europe de cyclisme sur
piste de la compétition s'est déroulé mi
octobre un appel d'un homme aux pays bas
les pistards français qui s'entraîne
quotidiennement vélodrome de
saint-quentin-en-yvelines ont réussi à
ramener huit médailles dans leurs
valises dont cinq en or mention spéciale
à quentin lafargue du vc le sky qui
remporte l'or sur le km et le bronze en
vitesse par équipes
le sportif évinois avaient déjà remporté
l'or sur les km lors des championnats du
monde 2019
une épreuve qu'il affectionne
particulièrement en écoute sa réaction
il était invité sur le 7-8 sport sur tv
78 alors que nate du monde et aux
championnats d'europe deux médailles
d'or auquel on peut du coup rajouter
aussi les championnats de france qui ont
eu lieu à saint quentin en yvelines
courant août donc j'ai réussi à gagner
les trois gros championnat de l'année
sur cette épreuve là oui c'est une
discipline que moi j'affectionne
beaucoup depuis tout jeune et j'avais
déjà réussi à être championne d'europe
et championne du monde chez les ch et
des juniors
mais de là à réussir à faire ça chez les
élites c'était plus compliqué je suis
très heureux d'avoir d'avoir réussi
réussissent à cette année ses distances
qui vous plaît oui alors j'ai un profit
de 2 mètres plus tôt plutôt résistants
et long je suis un poste 3 aussi en
vitesse par équipes donc le couloir qui
fait le plus de distance de l'équipe
donc voilà c'est ça fait partie de mes
qualités
la question sur ce thème quentin
lafargue peut-il marqué l'histoire du
cyclisme sur piste comme l'ont fait à
grégory baugé ou françois pervis oui ou
non vient dujarrier
mettez vous êtes indécis et yann ont
fait un petit duel contre jean jean
l'air passionnés par ce qu'ils sont
également stables c'était difficile sur
piste comme l'ont fait il a des grands
pistard soit air lease a déjà leurs
poches déjà quand même il a déjà marqué
il est champion d'europe
hier le lot de médailles c'est un garçon
il est pas il est pas con finit donc 27
ou 28 ans à 28 voilà 28 ans il a je n'ai
pas tout l'avenir devant lui parce que
maître du temps non plus faut pas
exagérer mais quand même il montre quand
même des performances qui sont très
encourageantes
de plus en plus on parlait déjà d'un
régime plein du monde où les français
ont fait des belles médailles là il
confirme au championnat d'europe
donc je crois que pour la suite au
niveau des jeux olympiques tout et non
il va pas lui si tu me dis non
si on me dit pas tout sur le cash les
choses maintenant maintenant est une
compétition n'est jamais jouer à vals
que ce soit n'importe laquelle
bon apparemment ian lui a des infos il
n'y aura pas de médaille aux jeux
olympiques
moi je dis que cela soit il ramènera une
médaille des jeux olympiques je vois là
je vais la soirée aujourd'hui je vous
précise jean c'est parce que le
kilomètre n'est pas aux jeux olympiques
c'est en général pas du kilomètre il
ramène une médaille de bronze en vitesse
par équipes va effectivement voilà donc
il sera autre chose ont acquis par voilà
qu'il n'ya pas que le kilomètre je sais
bien que le pire est à ça je savais le
kilomètre n'est pas mais il fait une
médaille par équipes projets pleins
d'europe
il avoue nouveau piéger à mon avis je
suis pas un spécialiste mais je suis je
rappelle quand même son palmarès il a
gagné une médaille d'or lors d'un
championnat du monde il a remporté sept
médailles lors d'un championnat du monde
il a remporté trois médailles d'or aux
championnats d'europe et sept médailles
en tout aux championnats d'europe
bon alors qu'il a déjà largué lisnard ou
le en effet ça commence à être un
palmarès qui devient intéressant mais la
problématique c'est que aujourd'hui si
on prend le palmarès de grégory baugé
ces cinq ou six titres de champion du
monde
si on prend celui là le titre de la ssii
de championnat mais il en a pas même
avec celui qui veut capter avec ce conte
est perdu neuf titres neuf titres
d'accord françois pervis c'est pareil
c'est beaucoup beaucoup de titres on
doit être trouvée le satellite est donc
florian rousseau bébé alors et voilà et
alors est le problème
et pour pouvoir entrer dans l'histoire
de notre sport quand on épie star c'est
plus des titres de champion du monde
qu'il faut ce qu'il faut c'est être
champion olympique
et oui et et l'a donc à problématique
pour quentin c'est que le kilomètre
n'apparaît pas au programme des jeux
olympiques et sur la vitesse par équipes
bien j'ai j'ai peur que l'on soit
médaillés mais on soit pas champion
olympique encore cette année on a une
équipe de haut de hollande enfin royal à
hollande qui type domine le sprint
mondial depuis depuis deux saisons cité
et donc donc voilà c'est vrai que c'est
vrai que la problématique elle est là
c'est que pour pouvoir marquer notre
sport et pour pouvoir marc sortir du lot
il faut être champion olympique et je
pense que ça va être encore compliqué ça
va être compliqué cette année pour pour
nos sportifs le mot je suis partagé je
suis partagé
reste à savoir qu'est ce que c'est que
marquer l'histoire
dans un sport là on vient de la violence
et françois pervis par exemple a emporté
trois titres de champion du monde
c'était en 2015 3,6 contre les meilleurs
il a marqué l'histoire parce que la
halle à l'église de grâce à ce titre
premier a gagné les trois titres du
sprint et la même année elle ne l'est
jamais été fait avant ni brasse de
médecine équine dans ceci n'arrive
quasiment jamais pour un rapide arrêt
jean m'a convaincu sur la partie sur la
partie déjà sur le potentiel de du
bonhomme
yann sur la partie potentiel des
épreuves
malheureusement avec une limite sur le
kilomètre mais c'est un garçon qui aura
33 ans en 2024
il ya tokyo avant
il ya peut-être il ya peut-être
justement de quoi arriver en pleine
fleur de l'âge il me paraît assez
costaud et s est physiquement prêt à
n'importe quel type d'épreuves sur une
bicyclette donc
donc je dirais que il lui reste de quoi
s'approchait d'un palmarès historique
juste sera lente et ça ne comptait que
notre regretté le poulidor nationale qui
n'est malheureusement aujourd'hui il n'a
jamais gagné grand chose et pourquoi il
est donc de la sarre joue bien ce que je
disais et là je suis d'accord
non mais c'est vrai j'avais un peu peur
non mais tout a été dit après comme on
disait
2020 2024 c'est là où
ou après plomb au sol justement gagné
trois médailles d'or j aurais aimé
césaire de fort c'est là que ça se passe
c'est de là que la différence se fait
bien sûr sans médaille
quel âge j'ai tout cas la maladie le
japon est une grosse terre de vélo
devait louer le site l'escalier qui agit
alors un incident au japon risque d'être
très très peu puisque ils ont ils ont
quand même recruter le meilleur
entraîneur français qui est je vous fais
sont encore et c'est pas grave qui a
entraîné les chinois et qui les a
montées sur le nom qui aboutit au titre
au titre national au titre international
eri children son titre olympique
chinoise donc voilà c'est benoît vêtu
voilà le nom est revenu c'est le
meilleur entraîneur et on aimerait enfin
moi je trouve ce serait normal soit
l'entraîneur français mais c'est très
très compliqué et donc oui les japonais
risquent la douche sonner très très bon
risque de très très bons lors de leur
lit aussi en vélo et puis faut pas rêver
les anglais vont aussi sortir sortir de
nulle part pour comme d'habitude ça
problème quand même quentin lafargue
il est pas entre deux générations
finalement entre les bauges et pervis
qui sont plutôt vers la fin voir la fin
pour françois pervis qui devrait sans
aucun doute quitter l'équipe de francs
explique a déjà quitté bien effectué à
l'agrafer alors il ne l'a pas quittée
parce que s'il avait quitté ça aurait
été de ce fait c'est plus elle était
viré parce que c'est la fedecam
importante pour lui ce pensent donc
entre les françois pervis et les griots
et baugé qui approche des 33 34 35 ans
et les vigier et la halle qui ont eu
tout juste 20 ans une vingtaine d' une
vingtaine d'années maps est ce qu'il
n'est pas si pourri deux eaux justement
c'est vrai qu'il a été il aura ce
problème là pour s'affirmer pour être la
star
il arrive d'attirer un peu isolé pendant
pendant une bonne pointe pendant une
grosse partie de sa carrière en effet il
a été un peu tout seul en plus il a
quand même été il a aussi naviguer dans
des eaux troubles
à une époque où
on va pas rappeler les jeux olympiques
de rio mais c'était très très compliqué
pour l'équipe de france à ce moment là
voilà donc vous êtes invités à y trouver
de l'argent ailleurs en vitesse leur
apparition en équipe
mais non c'était très très difficile
donc une période qui était qui était
compliqué pour la piste est en effet
aujourd'hui ben la piste va mieux et en
effet du coup quand un an profite aussi
et les résultats les résultats
s'améliorent mais après voilà à 28 ans
il est loin d'être loin d'être encore
fini il lui reste voilà on voit les
gorilles à gori bouger aujourd'hui qu'il
ya trente trois ans qui fait encore de
très belles performances sur sur le
départ puisqu'il va de ses spécialités
sur une départ de la vitesse par équipes
il y'a du y a du potentiel il ya il ya
des choses est donc le vrai faux faux
encore faut encore travailler ses c1
c'est un super gars il est vraiment très
très très très très sympathique et est
donc je lui souhaite tout les toutes les
réussites possible et c'est quand même
aussi un très très gros bosseur il ne
laisse rien au hasard a juste un tout
petit détail qu'il avait c'était le
premier français à avoir envoyé ses
combinaisons chez un fabricant pour
pouvoir avoir une poche intégrée pour
son dossard alors que les coureurs
français ne l'avait pas vraiment il
réfléchit à tout il pense vraiment que
enfin voilà les gars marino sont
importants et il va vraiment dans tous
les détails pour pour ça se passera sur
cette thématique
on va maintenant parler à deux boxes
marine petit a réussi son combat de
reprise le sportif qui censier chez la
team farrugia et l'encours était allé
s'imposer aux points face au français
karim menasria ce samedi à guérande
une victoire qui permet aux boxeurs
yvelinois de se remettre en jambes lui
qui n'avait pas boxé depuis février
dernier pour un titre européen des poids
légers
marvin affichent maintenant un bilan de
25 victoires deux défaites et un nul
la question sur ce thème secondes ce
combat va t'il lui permettre d'aller
plus haut oui ou non
un petit duel entre hélène et jan heylen
je pense que toute façon toute victoire
est toute motivation permet d'aller plus
haut après c'est tout ce que j'ai à son
adversaire nom n'est jamais lent de huit
victoires 23 défaites et un nul face à
deux reprises ça aide
non mais tout est beau tout est bon pour
voilà pour avancer après il faut pas se
reposer sur les lauriers d'une victoire
alors relativement facile voilà mairie
là il a des matches prévus qu'en
maintenant pour un sens pas le match
ouais prévu faudrait pas qu'on va prévus
devraient avoir des combats normalement
début d'année prochaine
mais là faut vraiment reprendre prendre
n'est pas de se démarquer beaucoup
l'année prochaine si non simplement
cliquer enfin c'est pas le combat qui va
faire en sorte qu'il va pouvoir aller
retourner vers une conquête européenne
nous avons quatre modèles parce que
j'aille l'a perdu il veut il veut donc
voilà c'est un début de reprise et 2019
en belgique effectif c'est un combat de
reprise c'est donc il va falloir aller
chercher d'autres adversaires et à
refaire ses gammes et un refaire ses
preuves pour pouvoir peut-être l'année
prochaine fin d'année prochaine à
nouveau pouvoir combattre pour pour le
titre européen et du coup ce sera en
2020 2021 qui pourra qui pourrait aller
chercher une un combat pour pour un
point titre mondial donc voilà il ya
encore du chemin
c'est pas celui là qui va faire en sorte
à la il s'agit c'est s'est un peu tous
les tours tous les matches que tony yoka
a pu faire a pu faire dernièrement voilà
on connaît résultats et puis ça ça se
termine et là en plus
mine de rien il n'a pas gagné avant la
limite il gagne un point donc pour un as
sur un adversaire qui n'est pas qu'ils
étaient quand même largement à sa portée
gagne aux points donc là il faut
comprendre les conséquences et se dire
faut retourner au boulot de faire
justement des petits combats comme celui
là pour se remettre en jambes
pierre chevalier ça me semble ça me
semble évident mais d'une manière
générale je trouve que les saisons de
boxe sont quand même assez compliqué à
gérer pour les pour les boxeurs on en
parlait il faut trouver des adversaires
parce que ses adversaires ça karim
menasria a été prévu à la dernière
minute il faut promouvoir promouvoir les
combats les montées après les financer
aussi ça me paraît à tous les niveaux
tous les niveaux compliqué quand on
n'est pas dans la lumière il faut il
faut justement se trouvait au delà des
sparring partner il faut trouver des
adversaires et alors petit match reste à
savoir ce que ce que ce que sont des
petits combats tout ce qui va le mettre
en jambes le mettre en rythme là moi je
répondais oui à cette question en disant
que c'est au moins ça leur lance ça met
un peu plus d'actualité il est gay les
projecteurs sur lui sur un combat dont
le résultat sportif n'est pas très très
révélateur je suis d'accord avec avec
yann donc c'est pas forcément c'est pas
forcément là dessus qu'on va bâtir une
carrière en tout cas hier soir il sort
un petit peu de sa retraite
dernier derrière les titres perdus il
faut de l'entraînement il faut de la
visibilité il faut il lui faut des
victoires et des combats donc il doit
combattre way qui n'ont pas une
importance
il faut qu'il monte sur le ring dans des
conditions dans les conditions
officielles
même si c'est contre des plus petits
adversaires mais on voit que même mail
sur des contres des adversaires à sa
portée
c'est pas c'est pas facile de gagner sur
un combat de boxe mais en face il a
aussi envie de rester comme ça sans que
oui il accepte et en plus voilà voilà il
la lui je pense que île entière plutôt
du bénéfice parce que j'ai été prévenu à
dernière au dernier moment et les points
et je l'emmène et je l'emmène des gens
mais nos boules de combat donc
lui par contre en effet il a fait une
petit l'a qualifié de guerrier voilà
voilà
il n'a pas lâché dû faire drôle genre 28
ans non non pas marvin c'est quoi qui
l'a 34 34
il était plutôt en fin de carrière et
encore je suis même pas sûr c'était plus
se trouver mon avis c'était plus ou
moins mais oui moi ce que je pense aussi
c'est que il a été très déçu par ce
combat pour le titre championne d'europe
en février en belgique on avait parlé où
il avait carrément parlé de vol au
niveau de l'arbitrage
et pourtant j'ai répondu non parce que
parra passait par rapport aux eaux à
l'adversaire quoi c'est pour ça c'est
simplement mais je pense aussi que ce
combat lui doit lui permettre de
reprendre confiance et de se remettre
dans les conditions dans les conditions
normales d'un combat presque déception
venue du championnat du titre champion
d'europe en février donc c'est tout
bénef bon il a pas pris de risques parce
que là il n'a pas pris quand même un
client mais mais tant mieux cc je pense
qu'ils accumulent de la confiance pour
après préparer repréparer qui à mon avis
certainement sera peut-être une dernière
chance pour essayer d'accéder aux titres
champion d'europe parce que après ça
ferait la troisième fois l'on sait déjà
tenté deux fois il a été champion
d'europe il a perdu la paire l'est il
veut l'euro qui verrait au caire voir
conquérir un titre de champion du monde
d'accord c'est donc là sur mon dos de
faire mon avis voilà mon avis c'est une
remise en selle et puis pour qu'on me
dit il ya
sans trop de risques on va dire on va
passer maintenant notre page coup de
projecteur nous allons prendre la
direction de poissy le futur centre
d'entraînement du psg sera érigée en eau
de la commune près de l'hôpital
ça on le savait déjà depuis plusieurs
mois on connaît désormais la date de
livraison après quelques rebondissements
suite à des fouilles archéologiques
la structure devrait être livré pour la
saison 2011 de 2023 le centre de 74
hectares comprendra 17 terrains de
football un stade de 3000 places 4000
mètres carrés dédiés au handball et deux
dojos pour le judo on écoute l'un des
gestionnaires du projet nous l'avions
interviewé il ya quelques mois la
recherche du paris saint germain
aujourd'hui c'est de recréer un lien
avec l'ensemble de ses activités
sportives aujourd'hui nous sommes est
allé sur le territoire parce que ya une
histoire qui s'inscrit de cette manière
là vont couvrir cette à première fois
que le toutes les activités sportives du
paris saint germain ont par s'implanter
sur un même lieu une réaction par
rapport à ce son entraînement vous
trouvez comment
rapidement un petit tour de table
chercher devant plusieurs fois par
semaine puisque j'ai des jus dans le
coin j'ai vu que j'ai vu le terrain de
l'emplacement l'emplacement est déjà
assez privilégié j'ai scruté et
justement les retards quelques prix dans
le chantier dans les travaux donc là
effectivement on avait envoyé une lettre
on voit que ça on voit que ça a démarré
à 10 ouïghours et un planning to après
les fouilles et et les recherches qui
ont été faites sur place
ça prouve sa prouve si besoin était la
très bonne santé économique sportive
également du paris saint germain
ça va permettre aussi de m en plus des
pros et des garçons un coup de
projecteur chez les filles parce qu'il
faut l'oublier de moins en moins il ya
une équipe de une très bonne équipe de
filles au paris saint germain
et parce que le stade de 3000 places
sera principalement pour les filles
voilà qui je crois
elles vont continuer à s'entraîner à au
camp des loges du côté où les garçons
s'entraîner jusqu'à mende s'entraîne
jusqu'à maintenant pour les deux
également
et puis et puis c'est multisports du psg
avec avec en plus le handball le judo
est peut-être plus si affinités en tout
cas c'est une très très belle surface un
très joli coup pour pour poitiers et les
communes environnantes dans une dans une
optique qui va se faire plus tôt plutôt
d'intégrer le tout à la campagne
environnante et
et on va dire c'est bien pour le
dynamisme local dans ce coin-là des
yvelines hellemmes ce qui vous plaît ce
moi j'aime bien le fait que les
disciplines soit au même endroit par
contre j'aime moins l'histoire des
footballeuses à au camp des loges jouer
je comprends pas pourquoi on rapatrie
pas tout le monde a envie peut-être une
histoire de budget de place de très bien
mais il ya encore une fois ci sur le
pour les matches je suis quand même je
suis quand même en bété qu'elles
bénéficient pas des infrastructures du
tout ce qui est du secteur
je sais je sers il a fallu faire un
choix
mais voilà mais sinon oui il ya une
histoire je crois avec saint germain en
laye qui voudrait garder le nom
forcément et il faudrait garder une
équipe à son genre dans les camps des
loges
plutôt que de rapatrier tous erp aussi
très bien à paris c'est impossible mois
ci s'est jamais genre bouclé son
entraînement il sait quoi dire un
terrain hier de réseaux liées
il a l'air très très joli et puis quand
même c'est quand même une
je pense qu'au niveau des structures
sanad voilà on l'envoie on voit quelques
images
je pense qu'au niveau des structures à
100 millions d'euros environ à tous doit
être high tech alors la question sur 7e
le sens d'entraînement permettra-t-il à
l'équipe de football d'avoir de
meilleurs résultats
pas du tout une alim
petit duel entre joie et eyal encore la
revanche maziade comme j'aurais préféré
commencer vous a été le premier à
dégainer bien sûr non merci
et pourquoi pas aussi la couleur du
maillot et et puis la taille des
troupeaux non mais là la peur quand la
gamme m
c'est pas parce qu'ils vont ils vont ils
ont ils sont déjà dans des dans des
structures qui sont magnifiques où ils
ont tout à fait de concession est un peu
vieillissant se visionne en fait quand
même vos comparer certains sites anglais
très correct à l'embellissement voit la
conclusion de plus jean ils ont passé un
peu le balayage ne sait jamais non non
pour moi ça va pas ça va pas basculer
sur le côté sportif c'est pas possible
c'est bien parce que 700 m tout nouveau
tout beau ce dans des conditions on va
dire performante mais ça va pas voilà
après ça s'est il sera pas du tout et
nuire ceux sur le sur le jeu moi pas du
tout pas du tout ça fait passer ça fait
partie du projet départ voilà il n'y
avait pas de véritable camp
d'entraînement
de renom pour le psg aujourd'hui les
qataries ont fait venir les grands
joueurs mais justement ce centre devrait
aussi aider à faire venir encore plus de
goran non donc du coup elle résultats
vont s'améliorer et ensuite sur le
travail physique et sur la toute la
partie récupération il va y avoir aussi
beaucoup plus d'infrastructures direct
puisque il ya une grosse grosse partie
médicalisé qui n'ont pas de leur union
ils n'ont pas tout ils n'ont pas tous
qu'ils vont avoir à foix s'ils n'ont pas
déjà à saint germain crois tu prenais
ramener vos radios
les internats quinze jours ils ont pas
la cryothérapie par exemple parce que
l'info peinture mais aussi bien sûr que
si chez lui d'accord mais c'est vrai que
j'ai de se produire lui-même du coup
d'envoi on sait bien que c'est très
important de le faire dans la dentelle
dans l'est dans le quart d'heure qui
suit l'entraînement pour que ce soit
bénéfique
je plaisante mais met donc non on voit
là il va y avoir plein des pleins de
nouvelles le plein de nouveautés et donc
et ça nous permettra peut-être aussi une
chose parce que donc 2022
c'est demain ben peut-être que ça ne va
même pas de pouvoir garder ma paie plus
longtemps moi c'est quelque chose que
j'aimerais bien si c'est pas une c'est
pas des répercussions sportives qu'on va
attendre même si je pense que ça fait
partie
ça fait partie des objectifs mais c'est
surtout c'est surtout une valorisation
de l'image marketing et la communication
de la l'emblème psg c'est à savoir si
vous aussi vous restez de près ou de
loin autour de saint germain bien sûr
mais c'est une ça fait partie de la
stratégie et la vision la vision des
qataris sont arrivés à paris et c'est
globalement un objectif d'installer
définitivement la marque psg en france
dont classes et des infrastructures high
tech et est effectivement essayé de
garder les meilleurs joueurs pour le
prix d'un et marc et demi et puis
derrière de d'imaginer dans les
meilleures conditions
et je suis d'accord avec jean ils ont
déjà des très bonnes conditions
d'entraînement aller plus loin
sportivement gagner cette ligue des
champions qui leur échappe depuis si
longtemps et et puis là ils vont
continuer une chose d'aussi haut il va
continuer à ils vont continuer à régner
sur le sur le championnat pour l'instant
des équipes s'organisent derrière et
pour l'instant court derrière j'ai quand
même la légère impression que cette
année
réussi à grimper d'un cran alors oui ça
se ressent pas en championnat mais
parlons en ligue des champions dont ils
n'ont pas besoin de changer de terrain
d'entraînement j'ai je serai très bien
qu'ils soient champions qu'ils gagnent
ali des champions avant d'avoir des
enfants qui sont d'accord il m'a souvent
thibout sportivement en fait qu'ils
arrivent à des règles de faire tourner
les équipes mais ce qui est étonnant
cette année c'est que même quand les
camps les têtes d'affiché sont pas là
iliad est ce qu'on doit appeler au
départ des seconds couteaux ou
troisièmes couteaux qui sont vraiment
tout bon joueur et il arrive malgré tout
sauf à dijon dernièrement à gagner leurs
matchs avec n'importe quelle
configuration
le championnat ils savent que ils
peuvent jouer à 69 60 70 % et le
championnat au bout du compte ils seront
champions
et c'est pas l'heure et c'est pas
d'arrêt thématique nous sommes en 2022
mais quand même on aimerait bien et je
suis persuadé je ne pense pas quand même
que les structures sportives en retenir
un joueur quand même bape et ça
m'étonnerait fortement que parce qu'il
va et si le vendent
il arrive à construire pays contrôle
interne un traitement
des recettes autour du goût sans doute
alors voir maintenant parler des jo de
2024 savait plus précisément de vtt les
épreuves devraient devait se dérouler
sur la colline des encours point
culminant de l'île de france projet
validé par le comité olympique mais la
donne a peut être changé dans la tête
des organisateurs
le site poserait un problème
environnemental et des voix s'élèvent
contre le coût des travaux
le niveau de difficulté de lacaune idées
en cours pose également des questions
la commune de chamonix qui espère
profiter de cette incertitude et serait
candidate pour accueillir l'épreuve en
on écoute thierry fabre président du fce
sky qui a déjà organisé de nombreuses
épreuves et notamment la revancharde sur
cette colline c'est un circuit
exceptionnel
donc c'est sûr que pour nous pour le
club ce serait une superbe récompense
mais je pense que saint quentin en
yvelines
mais ce ne sera pas faire la question
sur ce thème doit-on déplacer le vtt en
dehors des lans courant doit toi ton
déplacés dont le des vtt andorre non
vous at-il à lille hellemmes
nous on veut que ça reste ici si on a le
comment dire le lieu et les
infrastructures et tout ce qui permet de
le garder il faut garder
d'après les petits questionnement comme
je les dis en prémices mais non mais par
contre les autres ou save échappe les
autres sylvine dit non non les autres
disciplines autour de de la bicyclette
du cyclisme c'est bien c'est bien ici
c'est bien dans le masisi
donc quand même si moins de 50 ans dit
bida accueillera les épreuves du moment
sauf que le bmx sera loisirs de 50 et
aux blagues m devrait également pâtir de
rambouillet pour aller jusqu'aux
champs-elysées voilà donc la source
serait quand même juste pour une
discipline à travers le cyclisme qui
partiraient à charron x10 pourrez
partager non monsieur jeunes qui
souhaitent partager mais au moins au
moins c'est centralisée et même pour les
mêmes pour les spectateurs
les spectateurs qui vont venir et qui
vont venir ici tout est centralisé
toutes les compétitions autour du
cyclisme penser qu'ils vont identifier
le théâtre de saint-quentin-en-yvelines
au vélo c'est tout ça on voit pas trop
le vélodrome le le le
le parcours pour le départ et c'est
paris 2024 donc c'est vrai il ya
beaucoup il ya beaucoup de
délocalisation qui sont induites
économiquement et sportivement pour des
facilités d'organisation sur ces
appareils sans fleuve c'est plus
compliqué sur la scène de loisirs 50 ont
eu lieu pour piquer dont mise à part ce
qu'on valait rien sur ces disciplines
vraiment que j'appellerais idiomatiques
vraiment et qui ont besoin d'une un
cadre vraiment particulier on reste on
reste à paris est donc là la proximité
de la colline de saint quentin et
surtout son expérience dans
l'organisation d'événements d'événements
cyclistes plaide pour elle effectivement
délocaliser tout le monde les
les spectateurs du cycle libre en
général
l'acharnement et chamonix alors qu'il
s'est parfois ses chances de retrouver
dépassées
on fait et c'est au tour de paris autour
de paris et on a de sérieux atouts dans
les yvelines
on l'a déjà mon histoire des coûts et
c'est bon il faut rajouter 3,3 trois
rochers et puis deux
noront d'un de bois pour faire un peu de
déficit et selon selon les personnes qui
contestent
oui mais bien jaugé ça coûterait plus
cher qu'un stade de france n'importe
quoi selon ses plans mais monsieur
aurait ben oui c'est l'un des sports qui
paient le plus cher ou de chameaux
knicks alors je me souviens très bien de
du comment du parcours olympiques de
londres où voilà qu'elle était vraiment
conçu pour pour faire du spectacle c'est
à dire qu'il y avait des points on peut
on aller va suivre la course à peu près
de partout c'était vraiment vraiment
bien bien réfléchi au malawi c'était des
rochers qui avait été posée à droite à
gauche des rondins qui avait été posée
aussi il y avait il y avait des
difficultés et des sceaux y avait
quelque chose mais c'était c'était juste
réfléchir je suis désolé c'est pas faux
pas
enfin bref faut pas me faire croire que
faire ce type d'infrastructure ça coûte
des millions d'euros ou faut arrêter la
même chose du stade de france
non mais après faut qu'on soit les
tribunes également et on a mis une
tribune de 6000 personnes nationale je
termine chez harmonix à londres j'ai pas
souvenir qu'ils avaient une tribune
davantage du vtt c'est que on peut
mettre départ ddd comment des
spectateurs un peu partout sur le sur le
circuit et donc du coup pouvoir comme
comme au golf je suis pas prêt ce qui
est pointé du doigt également c'est le
niveau justement de la colline
d'elancourt 230 m ce ne serait pas assez
c'est difficile
la relais pour les compétiteurs
s'assagir arlesheim knicks a l'habitude
d'avoir des compétitions de vtt
régulièrement et internationale
la danse est rarement là
j'ai fait ça au niveau local qui est la
course phare sur la colline des encours
qui réunit une centaine de personnes
gèrent ce qui participe c'est ça qui est
cher enfin venu à deux montagnes
ces objets coûte cher à développer leurs
montagnes
en tout cas le président de l'uci
d'accord avec vous david lappartient
d'accord avec vous jean miss
il veut absolument garder sur projet il
encourt elle évoque le dossier initial
et il veut connecter le site au
vélodrome de saint-quentin-en-yvelines
pour chamonix x ça ne serait qu'un one
shot c'est ce qu'il a dit il n'y aurait
pas de structure pérenne nous écoutent
oui parce qu'après du coup c'est vrai
que celui qu'on en parle mais seulement
cours sur une structure qui serait
utilisé pour pour forer pour former nos
coureurs avec avec déjà toute la
structure que l'on a juste à côté pour
pour pour faire l'accueil puisque ben le
cube le cube sert aussi bien pour le bmx
que pour la queue pour la piste que pour
les routiers quand ils viennent aussi
faire des essais sur sur l'épisode saint
quentin en yvelines
donc du coup oui si là il ya une vraie
une vraie corrélation on est d'accord
hélène est ce que c'est trop tard on est
presque en 2020 n'y a aucune décision
n'a été prise est ce que c'est pas trop
tard finalement pour changer le dossier
initial
il reste quatre ans non je pense que on
est capable de développer des structures
et de profond de prendre des décisions
de voter des budgets de développer des
structures en moins de temps que ça
évidemment qu'on veuille tell dadt oui
voilà on voit des structures qui ont été
comment dire monter dans des pays où il
y avait strictement rien je pense qu'on
peut faire évidemment on va peut-être
pas attendre 2001 2 mais il faudrait il
faudrait prendre une décision et s'y
tenir aussi arrêter aussi de se
chamailler et de voir ce qui est le
mieux pour la discipline financièrement
aussi évidemment la question financière
compte mais ce qui est au mieux pour wei
pour la destituer la discipline et le
fait que ce soit suivi par le public
aussi c'est trop tard pour vous changer
agents non c'est pas trop d'art ce qu'il
ya quatre ans quatre en quatre ans 1 80m
faire des choses 1,80 surtout moins sur
circuits vtt pas c'est pas non plus une
construction monumentale sais pas ce qu
on demande donc ce n'est pas trop tard
mais effectivement pour pour la
communication pour tout ce qui va autour
des jeux olympiques et il faudrait quand
même à arrêter ça arrêter une bonne fois
pour toutes
lannoy et puis travailler dessus vous
sûr parce que sinon là ça fait ça fait
pour moi ça fait un petit moment que
l'intimant que le sérieux quand on est
là à savoir si on va le faire ici ou si
on va le faire à chamonix
ouais qu'est ce que ça fait un petit
moment que le sérieux à mes yeux entre
chamonix yahia lepidi ou de la sphère
alter montferrand aussi voilà c'est fait
en ce qu'il a fait du chemin
il ya aussi l'idée aussi avec chemise de
célébrer le centenaire des jeux
olympiques d'hiver de 1924 aussi c'est
ça qui est évoqué pour un dollar mais
également approuvé là on a plein de
l'historique et plein dit oui plein de
dates historiques a fêté avec les jo
mais c'est vrai c'est vraiment une
question à mon sens de cohérence quand
on prend quand on pose là le plan le
plan des structures sportives qui est
des vents accueillir les jo de paris
2024 si on a déjà le surf et la voile
qui délocalisent à marseille mais après
si on les tire complètement cette carte
c'est la france et la france entière en
certes tout le monde y prendra part mai
mais on est quand même sur une recherche
de cohérence de village olympique et des
spectateurs qui sont centralisés au tour
de parrainer le projet de départ de dire
que justement la plupart des épreuves
pourraient être justes sur la région sur
la région donc
et d'ailleurs je me souviens que c'est
mieux de quoi bien sûr parce que le
village olympique
ils vont être tout seul à côté d'une
petite partie du vieux de la région il
suffit que l'épreuve chanson fait que
l'épreuve dès l'épreuve du vtt soit en
plein milieu du programme sur la
quinzaine
vous n'êtes pas la cérémonie d'ouverture
vous n'êtes pas la cérémonie de clôture
parce que entre temps derrière vous avez
faut se positionner il faut s'entraîner
etc
et puis quand je mets moins de quinze
jours après vous avez une autre coupe du
monde à l'autre bout de la laube bout de
la planète et du coup une fois que la
course a défini il passé vous passez à
vous passer à autre chose donc
donc du coup vous avez raté l'ambiance
des jeux olympiques et vous n'avez pas
été voir courir d'autres d'autres
disciplines
dernière question sur cette thématique
j'ai fait un tour de table est-ce que
vous pensez que la colline est en cours
ne peut pas avoir le vtt en 2024 est-ce
que vous pensez que le comité olympique
elle français va décider de retirer le
vtt elancourt non pour vous il ya
derrière elle reste j'ai moi aussi moi
je pense que ça la conférence
je pense que ça va dépendre s'il arrive
à 2 c arrive à rajouter des difficultés
comme ils le veulent mais on l'a dit
rajouter trois cailloux et de 2,2 au
dessus de sable j'étais aussi en tout
cas avec avec attention pas ce matin
notre page débats
on va parler à d'arbitrage dans cette
page débats pendant une compétition
inter départemental de taekwondo fin
octobre à trappes
on pouvait voir de nombreux jeunes
présents autour des tapis pour arbitrer
notamment in est une jeune sportif du
club de trappes âgé de 15 ans on écoute
ceyrac c'est parce que j'aime bien
arbitré par un arbitre
ça donne du coup
une certaine indépendance sur cuba
aussi combattante jeu tous les faits
d'arbitré ça permet surtout d'avoir la
double casquette et je trouve ça du pot
1 c'est intéressant
pour s'améliorer il s reçoit
régulièrement des conseils d'arbitré
plus expérimentés présents autour des
combats pendant les compétitions
l'arbitrage est un axe fort pour le
développement de la discipline comme
inès une vingtaine de jeunes étaient
présents pour arbitrer la compétition
c'est extrêmement important pour notre
sport d'avoir des jeunes qui
s'impliquent dans l'arbitrage
et c'est aussi important pour eux parce
qu'en tant que combattant de connaître
les règles et les fils aîné arbitrale
c'est ce qui va leur permettre
d'améliorer encore leurs capacités dans
les combats la question sur ce thème
doit-on obliger les jeunes arbitres et
régulièrement régulière hélène toujours
problème dans ses caisses
compliqué peut-être peut-être pas
l'obligation de l'arbitrage mais
d'assister d'aller vraiment non je crois
pas que ce soit une obligation serait
pas une obligation
enfin petit duel avec pierre et le loup
comme ça non mais je pense pas que ce
soit qu'on a besoin de parler d'une
obligation par contre oui l'intérêt de
deux d'arbitré ou d'assister d'assister
de près à l'arbitrage c'est vrai comme
le disait le l'entraîneur nast et
l'entraîneur c'est ça ça permet de voir
la discipline différemment d'améliorer
son jeu de façon son combat et je pense
que c'est important après delà les
obliger il y en a qui vont être
intéressés d'autres c'est je parlais pas
d'obligation de l'obligation
je tempère si c'était possible je
tempérait un petit peu le le champ
lexical en disant que c'est plutôt c'est
plutôt de les inciter à mais en tout cas
pour les initiatives que je trouve
fantastique
j'y vois énormément de vertu et de
davantage de belles conséquences parce
que premièrement je pense que ça ça
crédibilise l'arbitrage donc plus plus
les jeunes sont sensibilisés à
l'arbitrage et à la difficulté d'arbitré
quelle que soit la discipline
je connais pas particulièrement le
taekwondo mais j'imagine que rugby au
rugby ce serait
c'est une très bonne chose d'un site est
justement les certains jeunes arbitres
et parfois les obligés pour justement
voir un petit peu de quoi il en retourne
oui ça se fait ça se fait sacré
éventuellement des vocations aussi parce
qu'on a on a beau on a évidemment besoin
d'arbitrés et de bons arbitres qui soit
à la fois humain et technique pour
pouvoir développer l'ensemble de nos
disciplines sportives
et puis ça ça je pense pour chacun des
jeunes qui tentent cette expérience là
elle le disait aussi un petit peu inès
el ça leur donne de l'expérience en tant
que pratiquant et en tant que
compétiteur en battant pour le taekwondo
et ça leur donne un éclairage anti peu
particulier sur leur discipline sur les
performances qu'il faut il faut
atteindre et surtout sur l'esprit il
faut avoir pendant les combats
donc obligé c'est peut-être un peu fort
régulièrement
régulièrement en revanche ça c'est très
bien mais mais oui je dirais que dans
ces cas là poursuivons justement cette
volonté de créer des vocations
d'arbitrage et ça sort ça n'en sera que
mieux pour le sport en général
genre qui vous a convaincu pierre les
deux les deux 2 h 20 de mieux avec
personne nordey lui voulait voir avec
celui ci ont pris ce qu'on puisse avec
modération bien sûr c'est bien sûr
monsieur verdon jacques opus se quitter
ceux de votre base long terme
non mais c'est très bien je dis que
c'est très bien parce que pia en parler
au niveau du rugby ça se fait chez les
jeunes ont fait arbitrés par des joueurs
par des jeunes joueurs de la même
catégorie de la même a du même âge du
même âge et ça ça montre aussi la
difficulté
la difficulté du de l'arbitrage en
général toutes disciplines confondues
ça montre en tant que sportif la
difficulté à arbitrer et aussi s'agir
encore plus loin parce que on le voit
malheureusement pas au rugby monde le
voit dans d'autres disciplines où il ya
mouillé moment il manque un petit peu de
respect envers les arbitres notamment
football n'ont pas non plus caché
moi ça me fait toujours un petit peu le
bon de dire qu'en jouant les joueurs qui
sont à ras la en train de gueuler sur l'
arbitre fesses et je comprends pas
comment appréhendes culture voilà ccc et
et pour moi c'est choquant pour moi
c'est choquant surtout qu'après les
jeunes le répète tous les dimanches sur
sur les différents stades de france donc
c'est très très bien parce que pour les
joueurs sacrés et effectivement ça peut
amener les joueurs les sportifs à
devenir arbitre mais par contre ça
montre surtout que d'arbitré c'est pas
facile
et puis ça aussi ça permet de respecter
de pouvoir avoir un certain respect sur
le
le boulot d'un arbitre qui équipaient
pas évident du tout donc alors après bon
on va pas revenir à ce qui était dit
l'obligation tout ça non mais mais par
quoi le faire régulièrement et le faire
passer tout le monde ça c'est bien ça
pour moi pour moi c'est une c'est très
très sacré pas les problèmes des fois
quand le larbitre se retrouvent joueurs
justement après qu'il a qu'il affronte
des joueurs qu'il a déjà arbitré dans le
passé non non non non non non pas du
tout pas du tout parce que de toute
façon ils le font ils le font parce que
tout le monde le fait donc c'est que
bien le joueur le joueur à l'instant t
il n'est pas sûr sur un plateau comme
ils appellent ça il ya plusieurs petits
matchs et sur sur un match mais s'est
jamais sûr jamais les mêmes qui arbitre
les accusés n'ont eu peur de
représailles parce que justement il à
cette forme de respect tout le monde y
passe
donc forcément si c'était toujours les
2/3 même on pourrait dire attaque doit
traiter l'arbitré au rejet mais là c'est
pas le cas
là tout le monde y passe tout le monde
tout le monde passe à la place du vilain
méchant cas le sifflet c'est samedi que
ce vilain méchant j'ai passé dans ce
type de démarche
j'aurais plutôt tendance à dire non les
u15 ont arbitré des u13 du xiii les u11
et c'est pour ne pas créer 7 7
cette problématique de se dire et il m'a
allumé la dernière fois moi je veux la
lui mais cette fois ci pas justement
justement c'est les npc les amenait
aussi avoir avoir cette réflexion de
deux que l'on pas malheureusement de
tous les arbitres qui sont vraiment
arbitres en plus de partialité quoi donc
les intervalles et les jeunes avoir
avoir cette réflexion intellectuelle
donc moi je dis que c'est favorable
qu'il ya pas une supervisation par des
arts par des arbitres quand même pour le
taekwondo oui aucun d'autres cas qu'ils
font avec les jeunes il ya toujours
quand même un responsable qui vit qui
dit voilà qui permet un léger petit
format qui est qui aident église
vraiment il ya des décisions qui sont
déjà vu moi voilà ils interviennent nous
explique donc c'est vraiment vraiment
une autre vertu à ça c'est juste c'est
justement cette cette chance qui est
donnée à ceux qui se mettent dans la
peau des arbitres d'assumer leur choix
et là il ya quel que soient les
disciplines
j'ose espérer qu'il n'y a pas de relier
d alma et cible ce qui a fait défaut
c'est plus simple d'autres
culturellement culturellement il ya
madame rythme est bon 3 autour de la
gamme des marques du rugby du rugby ou
ou des sports de combat type type judo
taekwondo la ja culturellement il ya
aussi une forme de respect et d'esprit
sportif qui a un globe
larbitre là dedans en l'exemple du fruit
de la fusion de la république les à
prédire sont légalement justement c'est
ce et c'est cette vertu l'a22 poussé le
jeune à assumer ses choix et et derrière
éventuellement peut-être reconnaître
qu'il est qu'il ait pu faire des erreurs
par exemple ces décès dont ces cas là
que
que les que les représailles on n'en
parle même pas puisque justement s'il a
fait une erreur il faut le reconnaître
on n'en parle plus chacun après tourner
et se retrouve à sa place donc c'est
donc c'est le fait c'est le fait
justement d'assumer d'assumer ses choix
et ça c'est là où aussi le sport est une
vraie école de vie y compris dans
l'arbitrage mais en football c'est plus
compliqué c'est très facile si vous
versez dans le moule en bout de ce soir
tu préfères je préfère être arbitre
d'athlétisme armide à vis de la scission
football dh en plus y'a pas du tout de
contact donc c'est très très bien et il
ya beaucoup plus de ses vols par exemple
un arbitre sur 3 ar est au bout d'un an
football en ck oui mais c'est quand même
la responsabilité de la fédération et de
la commission des règles je suis désolé
pourquoi dans d'autres sports alors on
prêche pas je pense pas pour ma paroisse
mais le rugby le rugby vous dites oui un
petit peu même
mais gullit est ravie droite nuls ses
cartons bien sûr et certain âge
ces mêmes bases et même pas hélas quand
on voit et moi je me mets à la place des
gamins qui voit les professionnels ou à
la télévision qui sont là à crier à ça
du de larbitre injectée mais c'est
justement les former comme celle qui
abritait cros dreyer à partir
d'aujourd'hui on est bien sûr vu les
décisions arbitrales surtout que
maintenant le football fait appel à la
vidéo fait on des moyens le disions des
moyens techniques maintenant évoluer on
perd il ya 25 ans donc je ne vois pas
comment on ne peut pas intervenir là
dessus et
et à saigner un petit peu ce ce jeu
parodique des disques grand père il ya
25 ans quand il voyait les maîtres du
lait après la remise 10ème épuré comme
lui un rouge et c'est fini quoi il ya 25
ans sait pas c'est faux faut arrêter ça
et
complètement d'accord bah non c'est déjà
la fin de cette émission alors avant de
rendre l'antenne un petit mot sur
raymond poulidor le site east qui nous a
quittés aujourd'hui c'est mercredi 13
novembre
un petit mot sur lui on voit sur ces
images il était dans les yvelines à
chatou qu'est ce qui symbolise pour vous
le cyclisme en général mais voilà c'est
le cyclisme en france c c c'était une
figure il va il va laisser un vide
surtout parce que même les défunts voilà
tout le temps quand vous êtes sur tour
de france quel que soit le moment où
vous y alliez vous croisez raymond
poulidor
il faisait toutes les étapes commencer
nous a fait quelque chose à europe 1
bon bah c'est génial c'est maintenant
fini pour lui mais non mais non merci
c'était quelqu'un qui était amoureux n'a
qu'à trop dur c'est quelque chose qui
était prévisible ça allait arriver un
moment ou un autre
- la tour de france c'était poulidor est
pour beaucoup de français je pense
hellemmes aujourd'hui non mais c'est
vrai que c'était une figure de mon
enfance quand j'étais plus jeune mais
grands-parents mes parents voilà donc
c'est là la fin d'une génération de
toute une état d'esprit il fallait bien
restera dans du du cyclisme des plans de
course pas les bonnes donc c'est
l'éternel second du tour de france mais
ça restera une figure éminemment
populaire et historique en plus qu'il
ait traversé les âges parce que parce
que justement il y avait cet engouement
en france du cyclisme et ça reste une
figure sympathique et historique du
sport en général on va terminer comme
d'habitude par une citation aujourd'hui
en hommage à poulidor nous allons
reprendre une de ses phrases se sont
allés parents ou même les grands parents
qui parlent de ce coureur qui n'a jamais
gagné le tour qui a toujours fini
deuxième alors sa marque cette histoire
d'éternel second les gens veulent le
voir ce poulidor c'est poulidor qui
parlait de lui-même
à bientôt sur tv 78
[Musique]
pour